there are many popular sayings you may
hear every day well what do they really
mean so these expressions have origins
that date back to the 1950s and beyond
so younger kids may be perplexed about
their meanings if this is your first
time visiting our channel please
subscribe and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up because today
we're sharing 15 common expressions tips
today don't understand pencil me in when
you want to arrange a meeting but you're
not sure if you're able to attend the
same pencil me and if you this
expression dates back to when computers
and cell phones were non-existent people
would use a pencil and paper to keep
track of important events using a pen
cement the appointment could be erased
if you were unable to show up
roll the window down before vehicles
were equipped with power windows car
window fur rolls up and down by turning
the crank in a circular motion not only
did it take forever to roll the window
up and down but your arm would be left
aching after just a few rolls let me
check the Encyclopedia when it came to
researching a topic for school paper
performing a simple visual search it was
out of the question back in the day
people had to flip through encyclopedias
to find what they were looking for these
alphabetized books contained a lengthy
articles about every field of studies
you could ever imagine on the flip side
before the days of downloading music
albums was created on vinyl records
front side of the record had all the
popular songs and when you flip the
record over it was usually full of rare
and unusual tracks the expression on the
flip side is another way is pain in
comparison of carving copy when someone
says your carbon copy of your mom it
means they think the tube you look like
Buddhist Carbon Copy actually means this
term comes from an older method that
often is used to create copies of
written documents by transferring them
through a sheet of carbon paper as
pleased as punch as pleased as punch
means to be extremely happy and content
this expression originates from a puppet
character named mr. punch who was so
sinister he would get enjoyment out of
being evil sounds like a broken record
back when music was played on records
any scratches on the vinyl would cause
the wreckage of skip sounding like a
broken record means you keep saying the
same things over and over again
have you checked out is MySpace page
before Facebook came along my place was
the coolest social media website to hit
to the Internet users were able to
to my's their pages with flashing
banners background music and their top
eight favorite trends spin through the
ringer before dryers became popular many
people would wash their clothes in a
washing machine before drying them by
wringing them out the wringer was
pressed water out of clothing through
two rollers so the things been through
the wringer simply means going through a
difficult or exhausting experience open
the map and see which roads were
supposed to take kids these days
wouldn't believe that GPS systems didn't
always exist when it came to driving to
an unknown area people had to resort to
reading maps in order to find their way
around town check the TV Guide and see
what time it comes on every week a new
TV Guide was printed elected ORS know
what time and channel their favorite
shows were coming on TV guides could be
found in every single home and living
without one was almost impossible you
would be forced to flip through channels
all day long just to find the program
you were looking for look it up in the
yellow pages if you need to find a phone
number or an address it's as easy as
doing a simple online search but before
the internet was widely used the Yellow
Pages was a must-have telephone
directory full of addresses and phone
numbers everyone had a copy of this big
bulky book in the home close but no
cigar
if you come very close to winning
something you may hear the term it close
but no cigar his expression was used
back in the day when cigars was used as
prizes a carnival draw a bath back in
the day taking a bath wasn't as simple
as turning on the faucet and filling up
your tub water actually had to be drawn
or pumped from a well in order to be
used and that for the saying draw a bath
comes from I'm just pulling your chain
to pull someone's chain means to trick
them but the expression dates back to
the mining days when miners had to use a
potty wagon to relieve themselves miners
place a small chain across the wheels of
the potty to keep it in place if a
prankster pulled their chain while
handling their business the body would
go rolling away with them inside of it
were you surprised by the meanings of
these common expression leave us a
comment down below and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up